you anima has Us Falling for their
seasonal menu so let's welcome Chris and
Joe to show us what fall costumes and
dishes will be available starting
October 24th right correct okay I am so
ready I love the season it is my
favorite but you know you guys are known
for your focus on ingredients and also
seasonal menus so what do you guys
what's your game plan when you come into
the fall season yeah totally so um we
always change the menus every season
um just the ingredients and the quality
of those ingredients are so much more
important during certain times of the
year so the focus now for this season
um a lot of pumpkins a lot of mushrooms
Persimmons things a little more heartier
getting us more into the a little bit of
a cooler weather absolutely so let's
talk pumpkin
so to kind of play off of a pumpkin
spice last day which is super popular
yeah I actually have a decent following
on Tech talk we heard we heard what
you're following was and yeah I saw a
video where somebody put peanut butter
whiskey in a pumpkin cake
the way that we would do it yeah um so
I'm gonna just actually make it for you
we've got some peanut butter washed
bourbon okay so instead of using
something that's already pre-made in the
market we kind of do this in-house we're
gonna use an ounce of this
ooh I love a pumpkin spice latte so I
know I love pumpkin smooth cocktail and
then we also made a house made syrup
this is using pumpkin seed and then I
fold in some pumpkin flesh and pumpkin
spice sweeten it up it is a little bit
Savory but a little bit spicy too with
the pumpkin spice love the mixing and
flavors now why you why you do that have
you you try to time in on what kind of
food you're having on this menu as well
as well yeah sure so we have a couple
different cocktails that move into the
beginning of the tasting menu or or the
experience this is more focused towards
like a dessert so
um a lot more things a little more on
the sweeter side kind of like the
espresso Martini Play It's usually like
a very popular afternoon or drink so one
of the more popular dishes now is one of
our desserts that uses pumpkin pumpkin
gelato and a little bit of squash in the
in the whole makeup of it so this ties
into it perfectly now can we make a
reservation and enjoy this beautiful
fall menu and cocktail yeah sure so a
couple different ways obviously you can
hop on anima by edo.com on Google all
reservations are made through open table
or through our Instagram which is Anime
by edio Perfect now let's get this pork
going because we have to toss the break
let's do it oh my gosh I can just I
already know how this is gonna taste I
don't even need
wow okay that is incredible thank you
both so much thank you we'll be right
back